the NAACP is warning black folks
LGBT folks and other minority groups
don't go to Florida
it's dangerous Ron DeSantis Florida is a
very dangerous place a very interesting
article from the Miami Herald says hate
inspired leadership NAACP joins other
groups in warning against travel to
Florida
the oldest Civil Rights group is
cautioning Travelers reconsider visits
to Florida as they join other advocates
in expressing distaste for the state's
openly hostile leadership the NAACP has
issued issued a travel advisory in
response to Ron desantis's attempts to
ban books about race and lgbtq identity
reject a new AP class on
African-American studies ban diversity
equity and inclusion programs in Florida
colleges
quote Florida is openly hostile to
African Americans people of color lgbtq
plus individuals before traveling to
Florida please understand that the State
of Florida devalues and marginalizes the
contributions of and the challenges
faced by African Americans and other
communities of color and it also says if
you decide to travel to Florida be
advised Florida Public Schools won't
teach your children accurate
African-American history
um the State of Florida does not value
diversity equity and inclusion the State
of Florida doesn't welcome the
contributions of African Americans as
people of color
etc etc etc so a few different things to
this on the one hand sort of proving the
point
I saw wildly racist responses to this
online including people saying hey
Florida's only dangerous because of the
black people maybe this will keep black
people out of the state the right-wing
subreddit conservative was openly
celebrating hey you know what we should
welcome this this might make it so fewer
black people travel to Florida although
the post said less black people rather
than fewer but I'm giving it to you in a
grammatically correct way so a couple
different aspects to this first of all
the very reaction to this advisory by
the NAACP roves much of what the NAACP
is saying period end of story
secondly the fact that in the U.S
there are Travel warnings to different
states based on this sort of thing
points to the retrograde and backwards
nature of what's going on in the United
States but lastly as a literal travel
advisory I don't know like for example
the first thing on the list is be aware
that if you travel to Florida
um your kids aren't going to be taught
XYZ most people traveling to Florida are
going on vacation they're not putting
their kids in school so I hesitate to
take this completely seriously as a
literal travel advisory but I think the
point here is to be more than a literal
travel advisory the idea here is bring
attention to what's going on in Florida
point to how these policies in Florida
disproportionately impact marginalized
communities of all kind black votes
folks LGBT folks women when it comes to
the abortion ban that has been passed
and their families of course so I see
this advisory
not as you know the advisory that the
U.S state department has about traveling
to the Sinaloa region of Mexico where
they say listen significant cartel
activity if you get into trouble there
you may be beyond help from the U.S
embassy this is not that this is not
that but it is a form of activism that
raises awareness and it encourages
dialogue and the need for rights and
protections and points to many of the
things that are going on going on and
going wrong in the State of Florida now
there are people who saw this advisory
and said this is very unfair this is
very unfair to Florida as a whole
because you have so many parts of
Florida where even if it is the case
that on paper teachers are not allowed
to do XYZ it is actually in the liberal
parts of Florida it is welcomed nobody
is blowing the whistle you look at
places like Miami and Miami Beach and
other liberal areas the LGBT community
is welcome there are absolutely no risk
danger whatsoever black folks are
welcomed and I have to tell you having
spent time in those areas I believe that
that's true but still it's really
important to understand the underlying
message here even if state decrees from
DeSantis are being ignored in the
liberal parts of Florida which to a
great degree they are
it is still the case that as a state
Florida is not fostering inclusivity
it's not promoting equality it's not
combating discrimination in fact it
seems to be building it so I think
let's not dismiss this outright because
it's not a literal travel advisory per
the interpretation of some let's use it
to remind ourselves of the right wing
hellscape that DeSantis is trying to
turn Florida into he hasn't yet
succeeded certainly not in all parts of
Florida but that's not a reason to
ignore this so a very interesting
declaration from the NAACP we're going
to take a quick break we have a packed
program today
um I do want to remind you that we are
just one week away from Monday Memorial
Day on Monday Memorial Day this year
that will be the 29th do I even know
what year it is yes May 29th we are
doing a one-day membership special doing
what we can to jump start support for
this program as we build into the 2024
election if you've been saying uh maybe
I'll get one of those memberships I
don't know David I I kind of like the
show but I don't like you enough to pay
full price
fair fair Monday morning we'll be
sending out an email to everyone on our
mailing list with an incredible coupon
code I would love for you to get on that
newsletter at davidpackman.com you'll be
notified first thing Monday morning and
then we will welcome you with open arms
into the ranks of membership